all right essence
hi hi essence uh tell me uh where you're
from where'd you grow up i grew up in
inglewood california
tell me about your family
um i have a mom and a dad um my dad has
six kids my mom only has me my twin
sister
um
my
mom passed away when i was 15
i lived with my dad until i was
17.
so how would you describe your childhood
my childhood was lit as [ __ ] i'm honest
um i didn't have like a bad life for
nothing like i went to school
i was like a cheerleader
i graduated in san manchester because i
got kicked out of school because i was
fighting
but other than that like um
i ended up living with um
my grandmother after my dad ended up
going to jail
and then it was just me and my twin
sister we've been together like since
like forever and your dad went to jail
at what age my dad went to just 17 and i
was they tried to put me in foster care
but my grandmother was nice enough you
know take me and my sister and
my dad got to jail when i was like what
18
and
it's like history
did you start working the streets yeah i
actually uh started working the streets
because i'm be honest um when i started
living one way my grandmother got really
hard and i was used to like having
things and i ended up having my son king
i have a son he's actually six
and when i had my son king i didn't want
my son to ever have less than nothing
and i was going to jail for like robbery
grand theft and it was like i was going
to spend my whole life like in jail if i
kept going down that like type of path
so i decided easier path
with easier money
and
that's it and you've been doing this how
long
i've been doing this for on and off so
basically like three years
how do you know i'm actually 23. right
three when you're doing it on your own
or with it then i actually do it by
myself right now um i've been through my
trial and tribulations through
certain examples
but you know hey you learn from them you
become a better person so are you
working the internet or streets i work
the streets i work 69th and fig
if you drive down there you might see my
little tenderoni ass over there
you know if you want to have some fun
holler at me
you uh you have a problem with the cops
when you're down there yeah i do
actually have problems with them only
like a little bit some of them they
actually want to have fun with us like
they like seeing beautiful girls on the
corner like not all of them are so
serious like how people plan it out to
be like sometimes they trip in sometimes
they're not like yeah the cops are a
little more focused on underage girls
yeah like you know i'm of age like
they're not tripping
yeah and they're mostly tripping on like
honestly like guns and drugs over there
like it's figaro area it's more than
just prostitution it's drugs it's like
gang banging you know like so when you
see them all the time it's not always
just because like
they were trying to look for some
prostitute or they're looking for a
minor you know it but it is that type of
situation though yeah
and tell me about the the guys who pick
you up
um okay i had the nice ones i had some
weird ones i had
some very crazy ones like i the ones
that try to kidnap me
are they mostly mexican
yeah most of them are mexican white guys
um mostly mexican a lot i don't really
do date black guys i don't that's not
really my thing
why what is the reason the girls will
not date black guys um
girls don't want to date black guys
honestly because
one that they act very aggressive two
they
want to manhandle you they want to treat
you like that they're really your
property just because we do this that'll
make me your property just because you
get you gave me money for some sex i'm
not your property
and you know i'll be honest nobody wants
a big penis on their vaginas so
that kills it
[Music]
you've had bad experiences out there um
yeah i had um honestly i had like a
tree tried to like kidnap me i had a
trick try to like uh
act like he had a gun and like forced me
in his car
like i had a trick you know um
actually had like his girlfriend pull up
to the room where he was at and he
started [ __ ] going crazy like oh me
too like what the [ __ ] like i ended up
having to fight the [ __ ] and everything
it was like mad crazy
how much will you make at night
um it varies you can like i'm not going
to be extra with it you can make five
you can make on like your okay days you
can make from a thousand dollars to 1200
like on your best days
you recall your first date your first
trick uh you gotta call my first chick
let me see
damn i'm old okay damn that's like a
long time ago um
my first ever trick yeah it was a
mexican
he was like hella small hello weird
because i was too scared at first like
uh to do like the bigger ones because i
didn't know like you know how to react
towards me what they were going to do to
me but he was like a little he was cool
like it was quick easy got my money
got on
then you'll do how many dates tonight
usually it all varies like you know one
day can make your night two days can
make it online or you gotta run that
[ __ ] up and it might be a couple of like
do you have kids i actually have one
his name is king he's like where's he
he actually stays with my uncle and he
my uncle helps me out like watches him
helps me out you know do you see him
often yes i do his name is my brother
he's my best friend plays football he
loves football he's in love with uh
sometimes basketball but he's really not
into like
your son yeah my son oh he's your son
how old are you he's six he's six yeah
you had him early
yeah i did i was i was i was uh popping
that snatch kind of early right when my
dad went to jail yeah
i was wearing a little short shorts you
know tombow titties a little bit out you
know i started growing them they came
out of nowhere
tell me are drugs a part of your life
uh i'll be honest i smoke weed and like
my main problem is liquor i like to
drink a lot like that's my thing that's
what you know my drug is you know i
turns the [ __ ] up okay
you have to drink to do the this kind of
work
um i want to say yes and no no you don't
have to but yes am i like
in my profession in my in my um
my opinion because i'm more like
talkative i'm more extra i'm more
funnier i'm more finesse and willing to
work with somebody other than like you
know the normal essence i'm irritated
fee like if you don't i can't work with
you i can't you know have patience like
you know so that's it what's your
favorite kind of drum
my favorite kind of job john
trick um i like
them oh ass white dudes that just know
that they some decent chicken like they
know that they came here for a specific
reason they don't want to do too much
they just want to make like be in your
presence make you happy by just even
sitting around there talking with you
taking you out to eat who don't let them
tights
[Music]
tell me about uh
love is is love even a part of your life
when you're doing this kind of work um
yes i feel like you know um i fell in
love with somebody we're not gonna say
any names
but we see it shout out t babe
but um
yeah i fell in love with it's like a
part of it because not it's just not
because we're hoes and we do day tricks
it's not even like we always have sex
with him
it's not like that like we're gonna find
somebody that obviously likes us for
because we got like we don't got super
powers we want somebody to care about us
you want somebody to hold us at night we
want somebody to tell us lies too
just the way some regular girl want to
get to the lies
so
i feel like it is you know like you know
i've met somebody that say they love me
you know i hope so
[Music]
tell me about how this work affects you
emotionally
um sometimes you know it gets
overwhelming you know because you know
everybody it's always a downfall to some
things but you just have to understand
like you just can't give up like you
just gotta keep going like it's hard as
hell just to deal with tricks or if you
got problems with your boyfriend or your
dude every situation or whoever you
calling whatever
sometimes it gets overwhelming and then
like you just want to break down but
then you have to realize like you know
like i'm grown for
i didn't come here to just play like i
did once i started doing something i'm
i'ma give it a thousand percent or i
would just give up
you cannot keep you cannot fail so you
should always try to strive for better
if it like the worst you can go is go
like go
to the point where no return it's like
you gotta stand up you gotta look better
than yourself to realize like
you don't have to like
give up on the first time something gets
hard for you
you have to keep
trying because maybe you might hit a
million
so
did you have dreams of doing something
else with your life yes what you want to
do um i don't know if you could tell i
like makeup
um i do the extras i always wanted to do
makeup like my whole life that's like
everything to me
so do you look at prostitution as just a
temporary
yes you want to sell [ __ ] all the life
so who wants to stay on the corner
with code like no one wants to do this
we have to yes fun it's not like what i
feel like people make it out to be like
um
it's so serious and there's pimps trying
to kill you all the time like it's not
like that sometimes it's a party out
there sometimes you know like girls
getting their feelings and they make
their make a situation that's never
happened probably a situation meaning
like they could say they had 10 pimps
and they all beat them like knowing like
you had probably like two and nobody
really wanted you so you got mad that
you feel me they didn't want you they
didn't i didn't see people pass a [ __ ]
around you know like don't even touch
them so i was like
it's not as bad like sometimes it's fun
as hell
like as hell like you know you see naked
hoes naked [ __ ] who don't want we
don't is that how is that not fun and
liquor like come on
what was the best example of a i think
you got something poking out there
darling
oh uh
it's okay you just vote for this on
youtube that's awesome
i need it
tell me about uh
uh the best example of a loving
relationship you had
um i'm going to be real i had one person
that i really honestly feel like that
loved me
i mean like your parents loved each
other yeah like that um it was like
when someone when you turn your back on
somebody like even if meaning like not
like turn your back on the butt
if you like if you decide to not be with
them no more and something like tragic
happens like it's like
so it was like so like bad like
everybody turned their uh backs against
me i was in jail
and there was this one person that i
called and like he answered my phone
calls every day he protected me he when
i got to jail he made sure i was good he
you know fed me took me out to eat you
know got my hair fixed i'm like i
love you he's always been there like he
helps me with my son like and even to
this day like we're not probably like
having sex or talking to each other
but he's like a best friend
so i want that's like i consider that
like someone that loves you even
when you there's no more like emotional
attachments you know what i'm saying
like
it's not because i i only i'm helping
you or want to be next to you just
because i want to have sex with you or
be with you or think you're going to be
my husband or something so that's nice
what does this work do you do to your
self-worth your self-esteem does it
build you up um honestly it builds me
the [ __ ] up i love when people call me
pretty i think i'm gorgeous i don't care
who no one else says
and i like i love when people
like gas me up like but it gives me
self-confidence it makes me feel like
i'm the most prettiest girl like that
hit the like stage like you know
[ __ ] i'm better than beyonce if you ask
me you don't see it you're just
naturally confident yes i am but i love
when like i have a lot of people that
you know gassed me up so it's not like
so much like somebody like people think
guys go out there and be like so serious
and talk bad about the girls like no
they build them up like damn baby you
look sexy as hell i wish i was one of
them trying to buy some pissy like thank
you
what's the hardest part of doing this
kind of work for you
um i'll be honest like the hardest part
is
doing it and not like your worst fear is
that you hop in the car
and this was the wrong [ __ ] car that
ever happened like this was your last
call people do go missing
it's not like all sweets like i make you
but people do go missing people do end
up dead like you know my worst fear is i
do get in the car with you know like i'm
not that very big of a girl and i don't
want to like get in the car and
you know that might be my last time i
like you know walk earth
so that's lame what do you think the
most misunderstood thing is about girls
that do this kind of work
one i feel like they think that they
that we are all dirty i think we're
actually the cleanest girls ever because
i know
a girl that is
a square and she doesn't have sex for
money but she's [ __ ] five different
[ __ ] and she's still hungry and her
rent ain't paid any talent to fake lies
so
it's like
would you rather
do it from to five different guys and
they really honestly don't love you or
would you do it with five different guys
and you get paid for it
you know i'm talking about it doesn't
matter if they're cute or not like the
whole point is you're doing a sexual
favor and they can't even help you out
with a soda a can of marbles if you
needed it like damn
do you find it difficult that
you're livi you're working in an
environment where everyone's a hustler
like the the pimps are out there
the tricks are all you know usually
everybody got a job to do you know what
i'm saying everybody got a job to do
that's a good thing he's got a job to do
pimp's got a job to do holmen got
adopted to do tricks got a job to do
young tumble
so
how do you think working the streets has
changed you
um it's actually made me more confident
i was not as confident in high school
keep it real um
i
i carry myself a more smarter game game
recognized game
and like i don't know like
i'm more i got more finesse about myself
i know how to convince somebody that i
like them without even touching them
yeah
so
do you think you're addicted to the
streets
i'm addicted to the money but [ __ ] hey
i'm not these to the streets i don't
care about the streets i don't know i
mean the the the fast money yeah i am
i'm addicted to i don't want to go broke
i don't want to somebody give me 25 an
hour like you give me 25 i'm not going
to slap the [ __ ] out you don't want your
25
for a whole
60 minutes hell no
you ever stand back and just look how
crazy this this lifestyle is though
sometimes but it's not what it all like
cracked up to be it's really honestly in
my eyes it's not that bad it's
girls when you go out there here like
the worst that could happen is you
getting the wrong trick car
it's really not prince getting out the
car
like it's not like that serious it
happens don't get me wrong
but it's not that serious
it's not people really dying from pimps
like that like it's not like 1965 like
this is 2021 [ __ ] is scared to go to
jail
[ __ ] is scared to get maced and [ __ ]
scared to get tased and stabbed so hey
you carry weapons or mace
i will miss you the [ __ ] up yes you're
gonna give me ten feet or you would get
messed the [ __ ] up i promise you i would
drink the whole candle yes you've done
that before yes
multiple times
what have you learned about men from
doing this kind of work
men are uh very uh
unique you guys are very unique you got
a different kind of men
you got the download you might even you
might not even think he liked his booty
touchstone but this man does and you'd
be like ah threw me off
i thought she was a gangbanger i thought
she was gangsta
she like your little booty played with
now you're nasty you feel me like you
get all different type of vibes like men
and men are honestly like let's be
honest like they're all finesses they're
all manipulators they're all doing the
same thing like it was a guy recently i
met that said he has a fiancee yes you
have a fiancee you want to be uh
you want to be loyal to her
but you're dating one girl but you won't
date another girl because that's you
know you feel like you're doing too much
now like you cheat on her once it's you
can't take it back
and then y'all didn't i hate why when
like tricks like feel like
oh like they just like not it's some
tricks like you'd be like yeah he's a
nice person don't be a weirdo
don't be thinking like i fell in love
with you
because no matter how nice you are how
cute you are you pay for [ __ ] that
means you'll go to the next [ __ ] when
we are together and you'll go do the
same thing you're going to pay for [ __ ]
nobody's that's pretty
to not get cheated on nobody's as pretty
to not get you know [ __ ] no it's always
a bigger and better [ __ ] than you do
you get guys tricks that fall in love
with you hell yeah but i'm rude as hell
so i really don't get him like that um
i tell him the truth i'm not your
girlfriend i did not say i actually want
to suck your dick for free you know tell
them if they do too much i get i like my
i have a white oh god i just you know he
asked for too much
but she it's always the way you like you
tell a person you know like
but with a [ __ ] like when they young
mexicans thinking they like hot [ __ ] or
i'm dating some old black [ __ ] i talk
to them straight up because they psycho
when you deal with oh white man he like
oh he's he gonna take it but he's gonna
think like oh maybe it's gonna do like
give time then they might change their
mind then they think they could take it
and you ain't taking nothing
yeah you'll get mixed up 10 feet
do you get risky requests you know do
you guys want to do without yeah stuff
like that yeah um i instantly telling
baby like you know if i say yes you
imagine how many people i'm saying yes
to you want to die i'm 23 i'm from the
live
yeah what advice would you give to a
young girl that's thinking about doing
this um if you're going to do this like
you know give it all your god you know
don't be ashamed of yourself don't let
nobody to make you feel like you're less
than something you know you think
yourself as a black beautiful queen but
you need to paint it you need to get
some money you need to wake up you need
to eat you need to keep trying don't
give up if somebody did something to you
and you have nothing
and you starting all the way from zero
you stand the [ __ ] up you take that to
the team and you go out and you go get
some [ __ ] money because the
only person that's gonna love you is
honestly the trick that's gonna pay you
because he's so trying to you know give
it to your all and [ __ ] yourself
so
yeah that's it
all right essence thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you for
listening you know
wish you the best of luck out there
thank you bye guys
you